[Music]
wheel hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show where the theories go
round and round round and round all
through the town so as the parent of a
child born in a post YouTube World there
has been no escape from Coco melon even
if their content isn't exactly to your
taste no no I don't like it e something
involving this entertainment Behemoth
has likely crossed your feed before
believe it or not but this right here
help me
[Music]
momy is the third most subscribed
Channel on YouTube right now and who
knows it might very well be primed to
take the number one spot someday in fact
the meteoric rise of cocomelon sparked a
bit of a feud with Pewdiepie back in the
day when they were about to surpass him
in subscribers he actually made a diss
track about cocomelon when they were in
a neck and- neck race for subscribers
which then got removed from YouTube for
cyber bullying and child safety it's
really funny I'm not going to lie that
said if somehow you've managed to dodge
this series please tell me how please
please get it to leave me alone anyway
Coco melon is a um a shell Network
Collection of nursery songs basically
it's like the infant version of MTV
right here on youtube.com where the cast
of animated characters sing nursery
rhymes to children and promote good
habits like eating vegetables and saying
please and thank you time to wear your
shoes yes yes I want to wear my shoes
riveting he said obviously not riveted
believe it or not but Coco melon's
actually been around in one form or
another since 2006 when a filmmaker
named Jay Gian and his wife a cartoonist
started making simple animated videos to
educate their kids teaching them stuff
like their ABCs they uploaded these
videos onto their YouTube channel which
eventually evolved D into ABC kid TV and
they started focusing on 3D animations
the channel began shifting more towards
nursery rhymes and eventually new
characters were introduced like the
creatively named mommy and daddy along
with their children TomTom yo-yo and JJ
the channel would eventually change its
name to Coco melon complete with all the
videos that we know and tolerate to this
very day now we here at Team theorist
are no strangers to the fact that these
shows made for children can be strange
and if you look at them through the lens
of facts and logic you start to notice
things that don't quite add up so when I
started seeing some theories floating
around online that JJ the youngest of
the cocomelon crew was adopted got
really excited I mean we've already
proven that another YouTube nursery
rhyme sensation baby shark was adopted
so could the same thing be happening
here well hold on tight friends cuz
today it's Morty time leave your
theories in the comments below I'll pick
my favor in the next episode of Mor but
before we do that let's take COC melon's
advice
and our coins for a rainy day because
when those rainy days come you're going
to want to buy our brand new winter line
of theory wear the Northern Lights
Collection first of all you guys have to
check out our new cozy hibernation
sweater this thing has a chunky knit
design it's heavyweight and has an
oversized cozy fit basically it's
perfect for keeping warm while you're
out and about or looking swave and
classy while hanging out with the family
and friends actually wore one of these
sweaters in a meeting recently and film
Theory creative director Lee
complimented me on it he didn't even
realize that it was something that we
designed and you know what that is the
mark of a really good piece of clothing
but of course the sweater is only going
to be doing you so much good if your
hands are freezing cold which is why we
also developed the polar Embrace gloves
these things are perfect for anytime you
want to go out this winter plan to go
skiing or hiking at all these babies are
waterproof and insulated keeping your
fingers toasty no matter what outdoor
activities you want to get up to and
that includes watching your favorite
movies theories and yes even nursery
rhyme YouTube videos on your phone since
the polar Embrace gloves also have
themselves a touchscreen finger no need
to take off your gloves every time you
want to change songs or find something
new to watch finally if you want to
complete the look we also have ourselves
the northern Ember beanie to add a nice
splash of color up top never been much
of a hat gu since they tend to cover up
that hair swoosh I've tried to curate
over the years but this beanie will
absolutely keep your ears warm if you
have to get up early to commute to
school or work listen I think you guys
can tell at this point that theory wear
it ain't just merch anymore it is
genuine pieces of fashionable clothing
that can actually be useful to you in
your everyday life pieces that'll last
years in your wardrobe you know what
you're going to look darn good while
you're wearing them please if you're
interested go check out our Northern
Lights Collection over at Theory
wear.com and stay warm this winter
season but enough Shilling for one day
let's get back to that Morty so the
earliest version of this fan theory that
I could find comes from believe it or
not the Coco melon fandom Wiki with this
page being created on December 10th 2020
and what's the evidence that they
present here that JJ's adopted one his
hair is blonde while the rest of the
family's hair is much darker brown or
red two there is no number two wait
really that's it that is the only real
piece of evidence that they're hanging
this fan Theory on I got to be real with
you guys when I first saw this it
surprised me this is barely a hypothesis
let alone a theory but believe it or not
there is actually a bit more to stand on
that you might first expect break out
your textbooks friends we're jumping
back into some high school biology and
hereditary genetics when it comes to
physical characteristics like eye color
blood type whatever it all comes down to
dominant and recessive genes you've
probably heard this like a thousand
times before so we won't dwell on it too
long basically your parents each have
two genes and both parents pass down
just one of those genes to their
children some of these genes take
priority over others thus making them
the dominant gene so let's say your
parents pass down a type A and A type O
blood type Gene you'll end up with type
A blood cuz it's the dominant gene there
but if both your parents pass down the
recessive type O Gene even if both your
parents have type A blood themselves
then you're going to still end up with
type O blood you can actually map out
all these potential outcomes and How
likely they are with a helpful little
diagram called AET Square which again
we've talked about plenty in the past
let's not dwell but all of that being
said that whole dominant recessive gene
thing it is one of those big lies that
tends to get taught in schools cuz
genetics go figure is a lot more
complicated than the short hand given to
it in those textbooks case in point hair
color instead of being a simple case of
the brunette Jee is dominant over the
blonde Jean there's way more going on in
a system called incomplete dominance
imagine you have a red flower and a
white flower in a typical Punit Square
system you might think that the red
would be the dominant color so if you
breed those two together you're going to
end up with another red flower but then
all of a sudden you get confused when
the flower turns out to be pink the long
and short of what's Happening here is
that the dominant gene is being diluted
by the recessive gene this is what
happens with hair color see the actual
genes being passed on here control how
much um melanin and fom melanin you have
in your hair and those determine what
color your hair is melanin is the
natural pigment that's found in
organisms um melanin is a darker pigment
and fom melanin is a lighter pigment
that often skews red typically um
melanin overpowers fom melanin so if you
have a lot of um melanin then you're
going to have black hair if you have
almost no um melanin and more fom
melanin then your hair is going to be
red blonde and brown hair then fall into
the spectrum between those two colors
thanks to incomplete dominance your hair
is likely going to be a mix of the
colors that your parents have and this
is exactly what we're seeing with Coco
melon when you really look at each of
the characters they all have slightly
different hair colors because they have
different amounts of um melon in so boom
there you go it's not only possible for
JJ to be blonde but it's possible for
all five of these characters to end up
with differently colored hair period And
even if we discount all of this it would
still be possible for JJ to have blonde
hair while the rest of the family
doesn't see a child's hair can fall out
quickly it can grow back quickly and
most importantly for us it can change
color quickly as a child matures the
amount of umum melanin in the hair tends
to increase darkening the color in some
extreme cases it can even take a child
with platinum blonde hair and turn it
jet black within the span of a few
months something similar actually
happened with me I started out as a
blonde baby before ending up as a
brunette by the time I was in first
grade out of curiosity I actually asked
around the team if this had happened to
any of them and no fewer than 10 of us
had the exact same story and you don't
have to take our words for it either one
study found that babies can have lighter
hair for between 9 and 30 months and
after Age 3 it becomes progressively
darker until it settles into the final
color around age five so even if it were
impossible for JJ to be blonde
genetically which again it isn't if he
were this young there'd still be a good
chance that he could be blonde while the
rest of his family isn't therefore there
just isn't enough here to say that he's
adopted Theory busted so is um is that
it well given how much runtime there's
left in this video you know the answer
to that one friends as I was looking
into this whole Theory I noticed
something else about JJ something that
is far more concerning than just the kid
potentially being adopted and it all
starts with his age if we're going off
the whole blonde hair that can darken
with age thing that we just talked about
that means that JJ is younger than 5
years old which visually checks out I
mean he's a baby but we can get more
specific than that so my first thought
was well what do we see JJ doing in
cocomelon that could help us pinpoint
his age as children get older they're
able to do more and more it's like
they're leveling up unlocking new
abilities and typically children are
able to unlock the same abilities at
roughly the same time some of the first
that might come to mind when determining
a child's age might be whether they can
walk or whether they can talk throughout
the series we see JJ walking on his own
without the aid of his parents or
siblings most children are able to start
doing this between the ages of 10 and 18
months this also lines up with how much
we see JJ speaking or singing I guess in
this case as I'm sure you know a baby's
vocabulary it ain't that great a goooo
here a Gaga there an average
18-month-old should only be able to say
roughly between 20 and 200 words your
average 3-year-old can say up to 1,000
words so how many words are we looking
at JJ knowing well despite the fact that
JJ isn't singing all the parts and all
the songs across Coco melon it is
implied that he's at least singing parts
of the
chorus
the and he's also got his own solo Parts
it's a great day on Lane thankfully
due to the nature of nursery rhymes many
of the COC melon songs have repeated
words and phrases cuz repetition is key
to a child's development and a parent
Insanity the amount of new words that JJ
says in each song varies depending on
the repetition of the song and whether
or not it's covering a new topic for
instance both here you'll be the
cleanest do I've ever seen and here I'll
be the CLE kid you ever seen the rhyme
and message are basically the same with
just a couple of words switched out and
then in other places specific words will
be reused to cross songs I want a bed
like big kids have a nice new bed like
big kids have oh wait there's something
wrong my bed is too big because of this
the number of new words that JJ sing per
song can vary between 7 and 20 though
the actual celon YouTube channel has
over a thousand uploads many of them are
either old videos without the cocomelon
cast repeats of songs that they've
already covered or compilations of
related content because of this we're
only going to be looking at the songs
released on the cocomelon kids hits
albums which will lowball the number if
anything there are 10 songs on each of
the 13 albums totaling 13 songs doing
some quick math there that means that on
these albums JJ has a vocabulary of
somewhere between 900 words on the low
end and up to 2600 on the high end
smashing that thousand-word average that
a three-year-old should probably be able
to say of course the mind of every child
is going to develop differently some
have greater aptitude for learning new
words than others and it is a children's
cartoon after all but this is just more
evidence to say that JJ's age range is
probably falling a bit older than you'd
initially expect based on his appearance
this also lines up with two more pieces
of evidence you might not expect where
JJ sleeps and more importantly where he
poops that is a sentence that I just
said that is my life during the series
we see JJ graduate from a crib into a
new cool ship themed bed generally
toddlers are ready to move out of a crib
and into a toddler bed when they're old
enough to walk around and climb out of
their crib just like what we see with JJ
roughly between the ages of 18 and 36
months anyway a baby will typically show
signs that they're ready for potty
training at roughly 18 months but some
studies show that only 40 to 60% of
children are fully trained trained by
the age of three both are ages that fit
with all our other evidence the toddler
bed the blonde hair the ability to walk
and how much he sings but the thing that
really cinched JJ's age for me believe
it or not shadow puppets in the shadow
puppets song the power goes out leaving
the cocomelon house in darkness and then
Daddy decides to entertain the family by
making shadow puppets solid dad move
that right there is Dad Pat approved by
the end of the whole thing everyone's
joined in making shadow puppet snails
and rabbits and all that good stuff but
the really interesting thing here JJ
joins in making a shadow puppet dog and
here why that's important being able to
make a shadow puppet like this takes a
lot of dexterity moving each finger
independently and then understanding how
objects can move in a three-dimensional
space and though children can get a
basic grasp of spatial reasoning by 18
months to be able to do this sort of
precise dextrous movement with their
hands and fingers these are fine motor
skills that a child Masters no earlier
than the age of three for JJ to be able
to do all this in the shadow puppets
video to understand how they work and to
make one for himself he has got to be at
least 3 years old but this then raises
another question loyal theorists does JJ
look 3 years old to you I don't know
about you but his visual design skews
much younger to me and one thing that
really stands out here is jjj's teeth or
lack thereof though each child is
obviously going to be different a kid's
baby teeth will start coming in as early
as 5 months with the bottom Central
incizors those bottom front teeth but
then the rest of the teeth can pop into
the mouth between 6 and 18 months
sometimes even as late as 3 years old
already though given what we found about
JJ's age and the fact that he has to be
at least three he should have most if
not all of his teeth that right there
that's suspicious but you know what's
even more suspicious the only teeth he
has are his top front teeth which should
be coming in after his bottom front
teeth now it's not impossible but it's
definitely very odd and it tells me that
something here isn't quite right after
doing a bit of research if you see a kid
who's JJ's age without a majority of
their teeth well it is possible they
might just not have come in yet there is
another possibility a darker possibility
that they have come in and have since
fallen out before they were supposed to
that might seem like an extreme
conclusion illusion to jump to but this
actually isn't something all that
impossible or uncommon in children in
fact it's a well-known disorder known as
hypophosphatasia or just HPP for short
and it's not something that I would wish
on anyone HPP is a metabolic disease
that disrupts the development of Bones
and sadly it can affect roughly one in
100,000 newborns basically it disrupts a
process called mineralization where
minerals like calcium and phosphorus are
deposited into bones and teeth without
this crucial step bones just won't
develop properly causing them to become
weak and stunting the child's growth it
can also cause your teeth to break or
fall out prematurely exactly what we
might be seeing here with JJ the lost
teeth is not the only sign that we can
point to regarding this diagnosis just
consider how short JJ is in the video JJ
wants a new bed we see several shots of
JJ in a typical crib and using them we
can see that he's the height of roughly
eight of These Bars according to the
consumer product safety commission the
distance between slats on a crib should
be no bigger than 2.4 in or 6 cm meaning
that JJ right here is just 18.9 in tall
for 38 CM that right there that is not
big it is smaller than how tall a
newborn baby boy should be immediately
after their birth some other symptoms of
HPP and infants can include restricted
movement and altered gate and skeletal
deformities all of which we see in JJ's
enlarged head and awkwardly stiff
animation from JJ throughout the series
HPP is a serious disease which can cause
a lot of recurring fractures in places
like your feet or your thigh bones it
can also lead to chronic inflammation
and joint pain later in life and the
worst of cases it can even be fatal it's
also an inherited disease so just like
the hair and eye color JJ would have
gotten the genes necessary for his
diseases from his parents this is the
true Dark Secret of Coco melon
underneath this happy family facade of
nursery rhymes and Children's
Entertainment isn't adoption it's
disease thankfully this isn't one of
those stories that has to have an
unhappy ending though HPP is a rare
disorder it's not impossible to live
with and there have been plenty of
advancements and treatment made in just
the last decade alone in 2015 for
instance the FDA approved an enzy enzy
replacement that would help patients
with HPP increase their bone
mineralization literally helping them
breathe easier the fact that we here on
film Theory have caught this so early
with JJ means that the cocomelon family
now has the opportunity to get him the
treatment that he needs a treatment that
will allow him to live a positive
healthy life while also opening the door
for more education about diseases like
this to Children if they can possibly
fit it in between their songs about baby
sharks and potty training but hey that's
just a theory a film Theory and hey if
you wanted to learn why baby shark is in
fact adopted we got that video right
here on the left spoiler alert you're
going to learn a whole heck of a lot
about shark Anatomy or if you're in the
mood for another dark theory about
children's IP check out our theory about
how the PAW Patrol members are all dead
that video is on the right hit the
Subscribe button if you haven't already
and I will see you all next week